a d-class drag races through the testing
Zone screaming at the top of his lungs
and doing donuts a mime who is also in
the testing chamber stares with
disapproval tapping his foot impatiently
did we mention that the cars made of
spiders yeah this one is going to be a
weird one folks stay tuned for one of
the craziest SCP stories you've ever
heard Emily had always dreamed of taking
a trip to Paris but the opportunity
actually came to visit the city she was
overjoyed she spent her time exploring
art museums tasting the bread and cheese
and walking through the city streets
taking in the sights one of her favorite
things about Paris was all the street
performers as she walked nibbling on a
panel chocolate she delighted in the
antics of jugglers tossing colorful
balls into the air she gasped at the
feet of athleticism and Grace
demonstrated by acrobats and
contortionists she giggled that the
Absurd shows put on by puppeteers and
dabbed tears from her eyes the sound of
beautiful songs played and sung by
musicians it became part of her daily
routine one night as Emily was walking
back to her hostel after a long language
dinner she found herself walking down
the street she had not encountered
before there was no one around except
for her it was a lovely moment of Peace
but it also struck her as a little bit
eerie and she wished for The Familiar
throngs of people up ahead she spotted
the silhouette of another person and let
out a sigh of relief as she got closer
she could make out the black and white
striped shirt the suspenders the Black
Beret the white face makeup rouged
cheeks and red lips a mime a real
classic French mime she couldn't believe
her luck when he spotted Emily
approaching the Mind began to start a
performance he began with a classic the
invisible box he felt around the walls
of the invisible box looking out with
exaggerated wide eyes and an open mouth
Emily clapped and reached in to her bag
for a little bit of money she could use
to tip him after all he was putting on a
performance just for her he deserved it
she walked closer to the mime looking
for a place to put her tip she didn't
see one so she held up her hand offering
the money directly to the mime as he
took notice of how close she was getting
the mime began shaking his head
vigorously eyes wide and insistent she
didn't understand that he was trying to
warn her until it was too late dozens
and dozens of spiders began to crawl
over the mime's face out from inside of
his clothes from his shoes pouring out
over the street and crawling up onto
Emily she tried to brush them off she
tried to run away but no matter how hard
she tried the spiders just kept coming
all she could do was scream in an
attempt to experience a little bit of
live performance Emily unwittingly came
across
scp-3247
scp-3247 is a humanoid entity standing
at approximately 1.7 meters in height it
wears a striped shirt and suspenders
similar to the Garb of a stereotypical
French mime as well as what appears to
be white makeup on its face and all
other Exposed Skin though these aspects
of its appearance seem as if they should
be removable the clothing and makeup are
in fact parts of the entity's physiology
and cannot be removed from its body this
is not the only unusual aspect of the
entity's physical form though it looks
corporeal and solid The Entity cannot
touch or directly interact with any
solid matter with one particular
exception there is a colony of spiders
living on and inside of
scp-3247 these spiders have officially
been designated as
cp-3247-a and are highly protective of
scp-3247 if anyone or anything attempts
to approach
scp-3247 in a threatening manner spiders
will swarm the Potential Threat as any
Savvy anomalous activity enthusiasts
might have already gathered these are of
course no ordinary spiders not only do
they dwell on and in an intangible mime
but they have a peculiar response to
witnessing a human being making specific
gestures or pantomiming activities when
this occurs the colony of spiders will
form the shape of an object related to
the gestures which they will then hold
for up to three hours or until given
additional stimuli that prompt a change
in shape while the spider colony is
assembled into shape they will be able
to share some of the given objects
functions in spite of being technically
nothing more than a massive
well-coordinated arachnids as for
scp-3247 it is either incapable of
speech or unwilling to speak instead it
communicates with Foundation staff via
silent liming when it does the spiders
will frequently react to its gestures
becoming effectively live living props
scp-3247 does not seem to be especially
thrilled with this likely because miming
is inherently a propless art form and
these spider based props undermine its
artistic Vision otherwise though the
presence of the spiders does not seem to
bother
scp-3247 in order to better understand
the nature of
scp-3247-a foundation staff conducted a
series of tests in each test a d-class
was given a gesture to perform in the
presence of
scp-3247 then the research staff would
record the spider colony's response
during the first test the research staff
ordered d-11424 to attempt to get as
close to
scp-3247 as possible they did not of
course warn him about the spiders he
entered the testing chamber and
approached the mime who was pantomiming
the act of climbing stairs as the mime
pretended to ascend an invisible
staircase and d-11424 grew closer
instances of s
scp-3247-a emerged to take the shape of
a staircase much to the mime's
frustration
scp-3247 stopped its performance
throwing up its hands in a gesture of
defeat the spiders turned their
attention to d11424 and began to swarm
him treating him as a Potential Threat
panicking and Unsure how to communicate
with
scp-3247 while the spiders were
overpowering him d-11424 began to wave
frantically at the mime the mime simply
shrug giving him a look that said well
what do you want me to do about it at
this point control intervened
instructing d-11424 to pantomime some
kind of activity fortunately before
turning to a life of crime d11424 had
spent several years in a professional
improv troupe and was well acquainted
with pantomime his performing instincts
kicked in and he leapt into action he
put a hand to his ear as if listening to
the ringing of a telephone the spiders
stopped their attack respond responding
immediately to his cue they formed into
the shape of a small table with an
old-fashioned rotary phone on top the
mime rolled its eyes into disdain at the
side of this prop based performance but
d11424 was on a roll he crossed to the
phone picked up the receiver and held it
to his ear hello he asked out of habit
he wasn't expecting to hear a voice on
the other line but then he did or rather
he heard the approximation of a human
voice created by a swarm of anomalous
spiders it sounded a bit like a human
voice sped up high-pitched and squeaky
speaking some sort of gibberish
realizing that this was his moment to
escape
d11424 placed the phone back in place
and promptly left the testing chamber
the spiders remained in the shape of the
rotary phone and the table for the next
two hours at which point they
disassembled and returned to their home
on
scp-3247 after his surprisingly creative
work in this first test it was decided
that d11424 would be the designated test
sub object for all future testing with
scp-3247 provided that additional
complications did not arise though he
wasn't especially fond of spiders d11424
was more than happy to accept the
assignment not that he had much choice
in the matter still it was definitely a
better deal than getting fed to scp-682
and it was a nice excuse to use his
improv skills again after a long
retirement during the second test d11424
knew what to expect from
scp-3247 for this test he was told to
pantomime playing tug-a-war with an
invisible opponent and an invisible rope
now that he knew his improvisational
scene partner would be a colony of
spiders he was able to enter the testing
chamber with confidence once inside he
began to pantomime pulling on a rope
having that rope tugged away from him by
a strong opponent and struggling to pull
back the spiders reacted right away
arranging themselves into the shapes of
a long rope one side of which was in
d11424's hands as well as a large
humanoid vaguely muscular in shape that
was holding the other side of the Rope
the spiders gave the Rope a sharp tug
causing d-11424 to lose his balance and
fall over the Rope slipping out of his
grasp aside from some injury to his
pride he was otherwise unharmed during
test number three
d-11424 was instructed to enter the
testing chamber and close his fist while
extending the thumb and index finger in
a gesture colloquially known as finger
guns sure enough as soon as he assumed
this position the spiders assembled into
the shape of a handgun d11424 was then
instructed to pick up the spider gun and
squeeze the place where the trigger
would be if it was a real gun and not
you know spiders a loud cracking sound
was heard when the d-class squeezed as a
spider shot out of the barrel of the gun
at high speed before smacking into the
nearby wall leaving a small hole in the
surface
d-11424 fired several more times e each
Shot firing an individual spider at a
pace that attending researchers
described as faster than a speeding
bullet after firing six rounds of
spiders at the wall
d11424 was instructed to place the
spider gun back on the ground during
test number 76
d11424 was ordered to hold his hands
together and wiggle four fingers on each
hand effectively pantomiming a spider
the research team was curious to see
what the spiders would do when presented
with a shape that matched their usual
unassembled form
scp-3247 who generally did not react
much to the experiments on its spiders
began shaking its head in mild
disappointment as approximately
640 spiders emerge from its body
dividing themselves into groups of eight
each group of eight spiders then joined
to form one large spider leaving eight
spiders these eight then split into
pairs who joined together into one
larger spider and so on and so forth
until there was one single Giant spider
made from the hundreds of smaller
spiders at this point d11424 followed
his heart jumping onto the mega spider's
back and riding it like a bull at the
rodeo as the spider bucked and ran back
and forth across the room according to
official transcripts d-11424 yelled
Yeehaw throughout this part of the test
until the head researcher ordered him to
climb down from the spider and exit the
room he was reprimanded for his behavior
and warned that if he acted without
approval again he would be taken off the
project and reassigned to a much less
enjoyable position as one of the
designated eyes on SCP-173
d-11424 immediately agreed to comply
with future instructions during test
number 133
d-11424 was sent into the testing
chamber and told to Shadowbox he danced
back and forth across the cell doing his
best Sylvester Stallone impression and
throwing punches in the general
direction of the spiders in response
approximately 3 000 spiders poured out
of
scp-3247 assembling into the shadowy
shape of a boxer and began to attack
d11424 the mass of spiders conducted
itself at the level of a professional
boxer dodging d11424's hits before
coming back at him with a jab cross lead
uppercut and rear uppercut before he
could defend himself
d11424 fell to the ground unconscious
and guards were forced to interrupt the
test in order to remove him from the
room and take him to the infirmary for
medical treatment after taking some time
to recuperate
d11424 returned to testing with
scp-3247-a it was instructed to mime
steering a wheel such as that of a car
immediately a number of spiders
previously unseen during testing emerge
from
scp-3247 arranging themselves into the
shape of a sedan
d-11424 was then commanded to climb
inside of the spider car and see if he
could start it he refused insisting I'm
not getting in a spider car are you nuts
when pressed by control to comply with
orders he made a rude hand gesture I'll
let you guess what that was the spiders
began to scramble to reassemble
themselves in response to the changed
gesture prompting control to stop the
test early to spare the researchers the
sensibilities with strict guidelines to
avoid inappropriate or violent gestures
d11424 was sent back into the testing
chamber with instruction to try out a
variety of animal inspired gestures in
Rapid succession he formed one hand into
a fist and made a peace sign with the
other hand putting them together to make
a snail as he made his hand snail crawl
through the air the spiders crawled onto
the floor and assembled into the shape
of a snail in front of d11424 though the
spiders moved quickly at their usual
scuttling Pace once they formed into the
snail they slowed to a gradual creep
d11424 noted a shiny slimy Trail left
behind on the floor as the spider snail
moved he was asked to consider touching
it but refused simply stating ew no next
he took his hands and formed the shape
of a wolf's head howling at the moon the
research staff were curious to see if
the spiders would form a wolf's head or
the animal's entire body they got their
answer as the spider swarmed and shifted
forming the shape of a full-sized gray
wolf the wolf padded back and forth
across the room before sitting down
lifting its head and emitting an audible
howl that sounded almost
indistinguishable from the real thing
next d11424 crossed his thumbs over each
other fluttering hands like a pair of
wings the spider separated into smaller
groups and came together to form
butterflies similar in size to a monarch
these spider butterflies began to flap
their wings and much to d11424 surprise
they took flight and swirled through the
air around him the d-class was so moved
by the beautiful sight that he shed a
single tear which he promptly wiped away
out of embarrassment control then
prompted him to try the next animal
gesture d-1142 4 used his hands to form
the shape of a rabbit several of the
spiders crawled away returning to
scp-3247 and the remaining spiders took
on the form of a rabbit the spider
rabbit hopped realistically around the
room twitching its ears and tail at this
point d11424 was instructed to offer the
spider rabbit a carrot he produced a
carrot from his pocket holding it out in
front of him the spider rabbit hopped
over to him and one Crunch at a time
began to eat the carrot until none
remained d-11424 appeared shaken up and
asked to leave the testing chamber as he
followed all of his instructions this
request was granted when he exited the
chamber all he would say was where the
hell did the carrot go it doesn't have a
stomach it doesn't have a mouth where
did it go
scp-3247 is kept in an isolated chamber
located in the arachnid wing of area 12.
it does not appear to require food or
rest but it has been provided with a
television and a collection of silent
films for morale purposes instances of
scp-3247-a are fed via a fully automated
system that dispenses 20 grams of live
crickets every week should a Containment
Breach occur staff have been instructed
to find a way to make escaped spiders
take on the shape that renders them
motionless then simply pick the spider
cluster up and place it back inside of
the cell it is unlikely that the
foundation will ever get an explanation
for where the intangible mime and his
merry band of spider performers
originated from but one thing is clear
they won't be performing in public again
anytime soon now check out scp-058 Heart
of Darkness and
scp-2427 a thing full of stuff